oh this is the coolest thing ever
history say my first Captain America
whoa who's that new guy I keep the suit
of course doesn't fit me hey guys what's
up get your PIN number wait a minute
you guys are the real Avengers I can
tell Hulk gives it away hey Amy P hello
you have 78 left shoe combinations
ricochet left
web Bernie
oh that was awesome don't spider me
don't mess with everybody you want
you move them working up here we go
do you know him to stop us you taping me
up
[Music]
this is race day my start this helping
him up his game with his suit and the
tech and all that
good evening Peter hello congratulations
on completing a train you have access to
your Zeus full capabilities thank you
the chute is the coolest thing that has
ever happened to me was just a dream
come true
you have 576 awesome allows your
combinations cetera oh well corny are
Webber nape reconnaissance room whoa
that's really cool enhanced combat mode
activate Taser web
super jump web links there's always a
real special moment when I put the suit
on oh shoot where you wanna do what
would you like to hear they're saying I
can hear what they're saying
activating an advanced reconnaissance
mode I'm sick of sitting around her
daddy is awesome I can keep the suit of
course doesn't fit me
finally here we go good evening here oh
you have 576 possible shooter for the
nation ha ha ha I can keep that soon
yeah done fit me where's our next
retreat what next mission
we'll call you all right it's not a hug
him to scram the top for you all right
there yet
all right kid good luck out there
hey Peter you coming tonight
I can't tonight I got the stark
internship what's up guys
mister here's my report for tonight I
stopped the grand theft bicycle hey
could you do me a favor hold on to that
there's anybody fight I helped us old
lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice I just feel like I could
be doing more wait a minute you guys
aren't the real Avengers hope gives it
away you move I'm working on
these weapons are crazy dangerous listen
fear are people who handle the sort of
thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys time we change
to my chance to prove myself we have a
Spanish quiz you gotta get better at
this part of the job
I'm Sam oh I'm intimidated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting hunger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol because mr.
start treating me like a kid
but you are a kid yeah can't you go stop
a boss with his bare hands
[Music]
[Music]
duh nothing nothing
you're the spider-man from YouTube my
ceiling
wasn't it what are you doing in my room
mailing me and you said we're gonna
finish the Death Star she doesn't know I
mean mrs. Jeb knows doesn't mean my
super that's in Tony Stark that are you
an Avenger ah basically this guy keep a
secret
Cyril I sure know what she's like if she
finds out people try and kill me every
single night she's not gonna let me do
this anymore
okay okay okay okay Kay I'll level with
you I don't think this will secretly
slick reducing has ever happened to me I
can't believe this
oh yeah I gotta go hey wiegel what are
you hiding Peter
[Music]
I'm skinny out okay but maybe I flash it
up and go with this oh come on sure NBA
Finals party I need to sign off on the
guest list
I left the guest list to you I said keep
it sophisticated done good
did you invite the kid you said keep it
sophisticated why do you hate fun you
really want me to invite the kid if I
invite the care that I gotta babysit I
like the kid I want you to invite the
kid can I please shave us off no you may
not because your team lost therefore you
have to look like me indefinitely which
one go for third option get out Friday
run a final check on the party list
question Captain Steve Rogers too soon
sending invites no way I'm gonna watch
the NBA Finals with mr. stark so you're
gonna let me go ha nice try buddy
[Music]
Oh perfect timing I need to go downtown
to get me snacks for Tim Duncan happy
the games starting here faster than
delivery with the hulk's thing now
remember it's for Tim Duncan so nothing
fancy just the fundamentals come on
let's go I'm expecting change happy come
on let's go
you guys are really screwing up my night
just want to watch the game I think I
know that guy
hey happy kid where are you it's mr.
stork man I'm not there devastating
where are the crackers I'm getting them
right now is there anyone Wow your DJ
Khaled you're spider-man what are you
doing here I'm going to this finals
party Stark's party I'm going to
what can we get a picture it's good look
low complete thank you Wow me that's
death we have first another one another
another one I got to go come on in keep
the change
can't believe I'm watching the final
she's mrs. Stark
[Music]
[Applause]
MJ MJ called me magic kid those from
Jimmy Duncan he's right over there okay
[Music]
snogging
he's did you for you what you wanted to
watch the game
[Applause]
got my change he's a great one time
thanks I've always loved the DIY aspect
of Peter Parker and spider-man Peter
Parker can do it so can I so can you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no oh my gosh I love it I
could go back and tell ten-year-old me
he would be screaming with excitement my
inspiration for this suit was spider-man
meets
spider-man homecoming I'm a little over
my head
goodwill it's like a treasure trove for
DIY superheroes
I bet Peter Parker shops a goodwill to
all you need to add is a radioactive
spider bite we wanted to look lethal
stealthy and just plain cool I cannot
wait to show the world my Spidey suit
I've been waiting for this moment for a
long long time
[Music]
that doesn't shoot anything actually
does this is like alright easy right I
got a three and half year old who has a
scarlet spider costume knows I wanted to
make a costume for him then I use 3d
painting to do this by the web inside
how long does he make that um about two
days in total I would approximate eighty
two years I basically spent the whole
week making it cuz I did a lot of hand
stitching to stitch on the fabric my
suit is inspired by Mexican wrestlers so
this is in honor of you guys go over
with your favorite submission at
spider-man diy.com
[Music]
but I can make a makeshift basketball
hoop if I cooperate sure you know things
you're the grills that were this is this
is a Z legit just a school just kind of
Cohen Wow look at that new guy who's
that that's my cue I gotta go I'm fine
with Captain American I stole his shield
up threw it at him with swords amazing
things ever happen to mrs. Oakes like
Andrews and I just sort of flipped in
hey just a second coming hey wealth in
Walsall the rich the powerful I don't
care about us with pick up bathroom with
eat their table scraps these alien
bastards are tough you gotta use the
stuff they use the world's change time
we change too
waise remix retreat next mission will
call you keep it a little more mentoring
if your real assets into you that's not
a hug let's grab the door for you oh all
right good good luck out there someone
is collecting stuff from Avengers
battles I'm building these crazy weapons
this is my chance to prove myself
what if somebody had died to different
story right cuz that's on you I wanted
you to be better eight years let in
trouble from those bozos up in stark
tower and it's no bastard red tights
shows up he thinks he can tear down
everything I'd go
I met a Plane full of brand-new Avengers
weaponry Delora
I'm out of business we're gonna take
everything they got
you're not gonna stop me
[Music]
do you know him - yeah still issue
[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
are there like trials or an interview do
me a favor can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man just stay close
to the ground
you're the spider-man from you two
can you swim in a Nomi of spiders oh
yeah No do you know him - still a shield
can I try the suit on
the rich and the powerful like stark
they don't care about us
the world's changing boys time we
changed too
these weapons are crazy dangerous
missing Peter forget the flying monster
guy there are people who handle this
sort of thing illegal weapons barry was
a 230 you missed it
what if somebody had died I was just
trying to be like you
I want you to be better I'm gonna need
the suit back but nothing without this
suit if you're nothing without this suit
then you shouldn't have it I screwed up
you need to stop carrying the weight of
the world on your shoulders I want you
to understand I'll do anything to
protect my family
I know you know what I'm talking about
so don't mess with
I'll kill you and everybody you blow
guy is still out there I've just got to
do this on my
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
[Music]
sup guys wait a minute
you guys aren't the real Avengers I can
tell hope gives it away listen new top
no you seen that before nothing with
that skirt you should probably stop
staring with Laurie cos creepy though
too late guys are losers so to become an
Avenger other like trials or any of you
just don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate oh all right
it's not a hug time to scrub the top way
alright good good luck out there
listen I know school sucks
Peter you still with us uh yeah yeah I
know you want to save the world but
you're not rid of your the sweater man
no I'm not I'm not this is just costume
this is from ceiling stay close to the
ground stay out of trouble
[Music]
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing you
can treat me like a kid all the time but
you are a kid this is my chance to prove
myself
what is going on with you I'm sorry I'm
so busy up slam
don't mess with because I will kill you
and everybody involved
underoos everyone
[Applause]
I get to keep the suit of course doesn't
fit me just don't do anything I would do
and definitely don't do anything I
wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate what's up guys
wait a minute you want the real Avengers
[Music]
but this does not mean you're an Avenger
case you were wondering oh it's not a
huggable scrap the door for you
oh all right kid good luck out there the
world's changing boys time we changed
too
listen Peter forget the flying monster
guy
there are people who handle this sort of
thing oh you've been treating me like a
kid but you are a kid this is my chance
to prove myself
don't mess with me
because I will kill you and everybody
you love
[Music]
[Music]
you